comme tout le monde
mais donnez-moi quelque chose pour aller avec.
Élevez mon âme avec une esthétique merveilleuse
et donnez-moi des outils pour changer cette inspiration
en compréhension et en action.
Par exemple, je fais du théâtre et j'aime le sport.
Lorsque j'ai créé ma dernière pièce /peh-LO-tah/
j'ai beaucoup pensé au football comme un moyen pour ma famille de migrants
d'encourager un sentiment d'appartenance à une communauté
dans le nouveau contexte des États-Unis.
Dans ce moment intense de xénophobie et d'agression sur l'identité du migrants,
je voulais réfléchir
en quoi le jeu pourrait servir comme un moyen de s'affirmer
pour la première génération d'Américains et d'enfants d'immigrés,
et leur demander de réfléchir aux schémas de mouvements sur le terrain
comme schémas migratoires à travers les barrières sociales et politiques.
Footballeurs ou pas,
les migrants aux États-Unis jouent sur un terrain dangereux.
Je voulais aider les enfants à comprendre
que les mêmes muscles qu'ils utilisent pour marquer le prochain but,
peuvent être utilisés pour passer le prochain obstacle.
Pour moi, la liberté existe dans le corps.
On en parle de manière abstraite et même conflictuelle,
comme « protéger notre liberté », « construisez ce mur »,
« ils nous détestent pour notre liberté ».
On a tous ces systèmes merveilleusement conçus
pour nous incarcérer ou nous déporter,
mais comment conçoit-on la liberté ?
Pour ces gamins, je voulais donner l'idée qu'il existe quelque chose à l'intérieur,
et que personne ne pouvait leur enlever.
J'ai donc développé un programme éducatif,
qui est à moitié un cours de science po, moitié tournoi de foot,
tout ça dans un festival d'art.
Ça accède au champ de recherche de /peh-LO-tah/
afin de créer une action politique pour les jeunes basée sur le sport.
Ce projet se s'appelle « Moving and Passing ».
Il croise l'élaboration de programme, une performance spécifique au site
et la politique du bonheur,
en utilisant le foot comme une métaphore pour la question urgente
de l'émancipation de la jeunesse immigrante.
Imagine que tu es un gamin de 15 ans du Honduras
vivant maintenant à Harlem,
ou une fille de 13 ans née à Washington de deux immigrés Nigérians.
Tu aimes le foot.
T'es sur le terrain avec tes potes.
Tu viens de t'entraîner à dribbler entre les cônes
pendant un quart d'heure,
et d'un coup, une fanfare débarque sur le terrain.
Je veux associer la joie du jeu avec l'exubérance de la culture,
trouver la place de la joie dans le jeu
à la même coordonnée physique
que d'être informé politiquement à travers l'art,
un théâtre en pelouse pour la libération.
On a passé une semaine
à examiner comment le milieu de terrain expliquerait Black Lives Matter,
ou comment le gardien expliquerait le contrôle des armes,
ou comment le style d'un défenseur est la métaphore parfaite
des limites de l'exceptionnalisme.
En étudiant les positions sur le terrain,
on nomme et on imagine aussi nos propres libertés.
Le foot, c'est comme,
la seule chose qu'on est tous d'accord de faire ensemble.
Vous voyez ? C'est le sport officiel de cette planète Terre.
Je veux pouvoir connecter la joie du jeu
avec le joueur toujours en mouvement,
connecter ce joueur
aux migrants qui ont aussi bougé en vue d'une meilleure position.
Parmi ces gamins, je veux connecter les histoires de leurs familles,
à la joie de marquer un but,
la famille dans cette euphorie après que la balle est rentrée dans les cages,
le sentiment le plus proche de la liberté.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)